we have a voicemail number that number
is 2192 david p
here's a caller who seems to think the
roe v wade stuff is related to satanic
sacrifice it's very weird very sick
hey david it's earth for math hey don't
worry about this abortion thing uh
you guys uh protecting women's rights
you can't even define a woman this is
all about killing babies and uh the less
satanic sacrifice that uh he loved to do
and selling baby pots
and killing babies in california uh 28
days after they're born now all of that
stuff is untrue i don't know if i have
to mention that but i will two people
are
sick
yeah
so once again you know we saw jesse
dolimore's interviews with some
anti-abortion people at supreme court
the supreme court yesterday now we're
hearing from this guy these are not
really people you can reason with and so
uh we we have to
we have to put people in power who just
won't try to pass this stuff in the
first place because you're not going to
convince someone like that
we have a great bonus show for you today
amazon is announcing benefits
in which they will pay for employees who
have to travel to other states for
abortions
okay
now this can simultaneously be a pr move
and a nice thing to do in light of
what's coming from the supreme court
we'll talk about it we will also talk
about how a record four and a half
million americans quit their jobs in
march and what it means and we will also
talk about joe biden's disinformation
board idea which is being likened to
george orwell's ministry of truth all of
those stories on today's bonus show get
instant access
by signing up at joinpakman.com you can
use the coupon code obama
right to get a discount off of a
membership at joinpacman.com please do
and i'll speak to you on the bonus show